[Musique]
pour la première fois un militant
révolutionnaire à la possibilité de
s'exprimer devant vous cette possibilité
n'est pas le résultat d'une quelconque
élection
cette possibilité n'est pas non plus le
résultat de la bonne volonté de
l'officine de propagande gouvernementale
qui est aujourd'hui le rtm si je peux
m'exprimer aujourd'hui devant vous c'est
grâce à l'extraordinaire mouvement de 10
millions de travailleurs en mai 1968
récemment monsieur marcellin le ministre
de l'intérieur nous expliquer que le
pouvoir était dans les urnes et qu'il
n'était pas dans la rue en fait lorsque
l'on sait comment monsieur marc cela est
devenu ministre de l'intérieur lorsque
l'on sait que le pouvoir gaulliste s'est
institué à l'issue d'un coup d'état
militaire le 13 mai 1958
nous pouvons calmement demandé à
monsieur marcellin si ce pouvoir il l'a
pris par les urnes
il l'a pris par les élections ou si au
contraire il n'a pas utilisé la violence
pour devenir ministre de l'intérieur il
est clair que pour nous jamais la gauche
socialiste ne peut envisager de prendre
le pouvoir d'imposer ses solutions à
l'aide des élections ou à l'aide d'une
quelconque consultations électorales
toutes les expériences vécues en france
ou dans d'autres pays montrent que soit
la gauche- développe un programme de
droite et à ce moment là bénéficient des
voix de droite et peut effectivement
obtenir une majorité gouvernementale
ceux qui aujourd'hui le cas de monsieur
wilson en angleterre ce qui fut le cas
de guy mollet ou mitrand en france mais
lorsque cette gauche développe un
programme beaucoup plus avancé un
programme qui ne peut plus bénéficier du
soutien de la bourgeoisie alors cette
bourgeoisie est prête à violer sa propre
légalité et à imposer ses solutions par
des coups de force militaire on connaît
l'exemple de la grèce et du régime
fasciste qui règne aujourd'hui
on connaît l'exemple de l'indonésie on
connaît aussi l'exemple de l'espagne
républicaine
en fait nous ne faisons absolument
aucune confiance aux bulletins de vote
nous pensons et mai 68 la montrer que
les travailleurs possèdent leurs propres
moyens de lutte
en mai 68 par des manifestations par des
occupations du sinn
les travailleurs ont réussi à imposer ce
qu'aucun bulletin de vote n'avaient pu
faire auparavant
c'est à dire faire reculer le pouvoir
faire reculer l'état faure qu'était
l'état gaulliste en quelques semaines
l'état gaulliste a donné ce qu'il
n'avait jamais accordé en dix ans de
pouvoir
mais pour nous mai 68 ne sera pas un
anniversaire que nous fêterons comme
d'anciens combattants ni un enterrement
ce que s'efforce de faire aujourd'hui la
totalité des partis de la gauche
officielle mais fut pour nous un immense
espoir
est ce que nous nous efforcerons de
faire à travers cette campagne que nous
voulons avant tout une campagne
militante
c'est d'expliquer ce qui s'est passé
durant ces journées c'est d'en tirer
tous les enseignements de montrer toutes
les carences aussi du mouvement de mai
de façon à armer les étudiants les
travailleurs pour les prochaines luttes
qui ne seront pas qu'ils ne peuvent pas
être des luttes électorales
les enseignements sont extrêmement
nombreux on nous a expliqué pendant des
années qu'il n'y avait plus de classe
ouvrière que le régime capitaliste
néocapitaliste avait résolu toutes ces
contradictions que aujourd'hui il était
capable d'augmenter de façon permanente
le niveau de vie or que voyons nous et
les travailleurs d'ailleurs l'ont vu en
mai 68 il existe des centaines de
milliers de chômeurs il existe
aujourd'hui des dizaines de milliers de
jeunes sans emploi ou lorsqu'ils
trouvent un emploi dans une usine
généralement le trouve pour des tâches
qui ne correspondent pas à leurs
qualifications professionnelles
aujourd'hui dans les entreprises les
cadences augmentent
avec la perspective d'augmentation du
profit en mai 68 par millions les
travailleurs ont pris conscience que le
problème n'était plus de se battre pour
telle ou telle réforme pour deux ou
trois pourcent d'augmentation
immédiatement reprise par le patronat
mais qu'il était nécessaire pour faire
aboutir leur principale revendication de
transformer radicalement la société et
de prendre en main eux mêmes les centres
de production c'est ce qui a commencé à
être fait par les occupations d usines
par la mise en route par les
travailleurs eux-mêmes dans certaines
localités des usines mais sans les
patrons une période de véritable liberté
a régné sur la france
pendant ce mais ce mois de mai 1968
à cette époque nous disions que tout
était possible et on nous a traités de
gauchistes d'enragés mais lorsque l'on
regarde de près la situation
lorsqu'on lit tous les ouvrages qui
paraissent aujourd'hui sur cette période
lorsqu'on voit la panique qui régnait
dans les bureaux ministériels déserté
pour la plupart lorsqu'on voit dans quel
état d'isolement se trouvait cette
grande bourgeoisie coupez les
travailleurs couper des étudiants couper
des couches moyennes coupé de la petite
paysannerie
on peut comprendre qu'effectivement à
cette époque si les partis ouvriers
avaient donné une véritable alternative
politique
une alternative socialiste permettant
d'offrir la perspective d'un
gouvernement des travailleurs et donnant
aux travailleurs les moyens de lutte
pour obtenir un tel but alors la
situation aurait complètement changé
alors nous ne nous prenons serions pas
aujourd'hui dans cette période
électorale pour savoir si nous devons
avoir un pompidou ou un poème à la tête
de l'état aujourd'hui en l'absence de
lutte ouvrière
la bourgeoisie apur stabiliser
provisoirement son système elle s'est
même permis le luxe de renvoyer de
gaulle à colombey les deux églises
il est clair que de gaulle a permis en
mai cinq ans
tweet d'assurer un changement décisif
dans les institutions mais après mais
l'instabilité du régime est apparue de
gaulle avait perdu énormément de
prestige et face aux nouvelles luttes
possible et prévisible la bourgeoisie a
compris qu'il était nécessaire de se
séparer de de gaulle pour envisager un
régime capable de d'affronter la classe
ouvrière dans les mois à venir
deux candidats s'offrent à nous poey
répond qu'il est pompidou chacun
présentant un programme extrêmement
différents comme vous pouvez en juger
l'un est pour le mouvement dans la
continuité l'autre et pour la continuité
dans le mouvement
voilà la démocratie voilà le choix
décisif qu'on nous impose aujourd'hui
mais ceci est possible parce que face à
ces candidats la gauche officielle
n'offrent aucune alternative
plusieurs candidats se propose mais nous
pouvons leur poser la question où
étiez-vous en mai lorsqu'il ne
s'agissait pas de voter lorsqu'il y
avait ces luttes ouvrières lorsqu'il y
avait ces grèves ou était mollet ou
était de faire ou est un mythe rend
cette question mériterait une réponse
mais je crois que tout le monde déjà peu
la donne et ce combat de mais elle n'a
pas su l'amener aujourd'hui elle se
présente contre la quatrième république
contre le retour à ses moeurs mais
demain de faire me tran mollet et les
autres viendront nous dire il faut
s'opposer
nous sommes contre les moeurs de la vème
république ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est comment avant comment est il
possible d'arriver à une telle situation
un an après mai 68 en fait la gauche vit
sur deux mythes qui la paralyse la
croyance aux bulletins de vote et la
croyance dans cette fameuse union de la
gauche pour nous et nous le disons
clairement nous sommes contre cette
union de la gauche car ce terme ne
recouvrent aujourd'hui absolument plus
rien si la gauche signifie une place
géographique au parlement c'est à dire à
la gauche du président du parlement
alors bien c'est une définition
géographique mais si il s'agit d'un
programme politique
alors nous pouvons poser la question est
ce que lorsque jules moch était ministre
de l'intérieur et faisait matraquer les
mineurs était-il plus à gauche que marc
cela est ce que guy mollet était un
homme de gauche
lorsqu ils envoyaient les parachutistes
à suez est ce que me tran était un homme
de gauche lorsqu'il parlait d' algérie
française
nous ne connaissons pas nous une gauche
nous connaissons une classe ouvrière
nous connaissons des organisations qui
défendent les revendications de la
classe ouvrière mais nous ne pouvons pas
aller au delà
l'union qui est nécessaire à l'heure
actuelle pour aboutir à une
transformation radicale de la société
c'est l'union de tous les travailleurs
permettant par la suite une alliance de
la classe ouvrière unis sur un programme
socialiste avec les couches moyennes
nous nous refusons quant à nous à
rentrer dans ce jeu des politiciens de
gauche quel qu'il soit
mai 68 a fait apparaître en france un
nouveau courant communiste courant
communiste pour qui le socialisme est
tout à fait autre chose que la
caricature qui existent aujourd'hui en
union soviétique pour lui pour nous le
socialisme ce n'est pas les camps de
concentration pour nous le socialisme ça
ne peut pas être un régime qui met comme
en union soviétique
des intellectuels en prison qui empêche
toute démocratie ouvrière qui n'hésite
pas à rétablir ce qu'il appelle la
légalité d'un pays frère en envoyant des
troupes d'occupation comme cela a été
fait en tchécoslovaquie
ce nouveau communisme ce nouveau courant
d'avant garde n'existe pas seulement en
france il existe à l'heure actuelle dans
toute une série de pays d'europe
d'amérique latine et même aux états unis
ce socialisme aujourd'hui n'est pas
incarnée par brejnev ou kossyguine mais
beaucoup plus incarné par che guevara et
nous pensons que mai 68 rend tout à fait
actuel la fameuse phrase de che guevara
le devoir de tout révolutionnaire et de
faire la révolution
lorsque l'on voit comment les occasions
ont pu être manqué en 36 en 1946 47 et
récemment en 1968
nous nous apercevons et il est clair
aujourd'hui que le titre de communisme
ne se mérite pas en achetant une carte
ce n'est pas un monopole d'un parti
s'est tu
qui se mérite à travers la participation
aux actions de la classe ouvrière
c'est un titre qui se gagne dans la
lutte de classe en ce qui nous concerne
nous nous envisageons à travers cette
campagne électorale de rendre compte du
combat mené en mai par 10 millions de
travailleurs et de donner les moyens de
le poursuivre
pompidou est mort lui dr agonise lra
s'entre déchirent ce spectacle pour nous
est tout à fait satisfaisant la
différence fondamentale qui sépare
chavent destin de giscard delmas ce
n'est pas la feuille d'impôts ce n'est
pas l'accordéon ce n'est pas le tennis
c'est tout simplement qu'ils veulent
être tous les deux présidents de la
république pour mener à peu près la même
politique
quant à roy y est vous l'avez reconnu
c'est le maréchal pétain qui parle
alors on nous dit mais puisque vous êtes
d'accord pour balayer toute cette clique
pourquoi ne pas voter pour françois
mitterrand dès le premier tour
c'est la seule solution réaliste et bien
nous disons non n'avons aucune confiance
dans françois mitterrand nous croyons qu
aujourd'hui c'est tout le problème de la
société capitaliste qui est posée c'est
toute la logique d'un système qui est en
cause
d'assystem tout ce qui est produits
lettres uniquement en fonction du profit
et non pas pour satisfaire les besoins
des gens là système par exemple où les
frais de publicité en france représente
le double du budget de la santé où
l'armée coûte plus cher que l'école où
des milliards ont été gaspillés pour
toute une série de scandales comme celui
de la villette d'un système où malgré
les progrès scientifiques les conditions
de travail de vie sont de plus en plus
pénible
une moyenne de 45 heures de travail par
semaine
c'est la plus grande d'europe un
accident de travail mortel
toutes les heures sept cent mille
chômeurs des millions de femmes qui
travaillent de 70 à 80 heures par
semaine
si l'on compte et il faut le faire les
tâches domestiques 800 1000 avortements
clandestins chaque année du fait d'une
loin p civ 2 millions de travailleurs
immigrés il est vrai qu'ils ne votent
pas mais deux millions de travailleurs
immigrés surexploités lié directement au
contrôle de la police et enfin trois
cent mille jeunes soldats qui perdent un
an de leur existence
le crâne rasé la cervelle laver et puis
pour protéger tout cet ordre qui est
leur ordre cent mille policiers
des centaines de barbouzes la fft dans
les usines des milliers d'écoutés
téléphoniques et leurs dernières
découvertes l'ordinateur safari plus une
armée qui prépare la guerre civile c'est
cela la société de profits c'est cela la
société capitaliste et sa face brive ou
bien on est contraint d'en subir
totalement la logique alors qu'eddy
aujourd'hui françois mitterrand
aujourd'hui pas hier quand il était
ministre avec chaban delmas du
gouvernement n'a des france celui 7
l'antenne il déclarait récemment comment
pourrions nous être contre le profit
dans une économie de marché où la france
se trouve par sa nature même par son
appartement son marché commun et par
laird influence américaine
qu'est ce que ça veut dire en bref deux
choses très simples
premièrement je suis avec les américains
et je compte bien y rester deuxièmement
pas question pour moi d'attaquer le
profit et que pense le parti communiste
de cette politique
il ne dit rien il se tait honteusement
alors réfléchissons un peu
si demain biterrois a été vue ce qui est
possible chabot et giscard s'en vont
tant mieux et c'est pour cela qu'au
deuxième tour nous appellerons à voter
pour mitterrand
mais le capitalisme il reste alors
certains disent dira quand même 9
nationalisation en cinq ans mais ces
nationalisations ne remettent pas en
cause la logique du système capitaliste
allez demander aux travailleurs de
renault si l'exploitation a cessé à
billancourt en fait mitterrand ne veux
pas effrayer les patrons l'homme m plus
loin
il annonce qu'il est prêt à indemniser
les sociétés nationalisées
cela veut dire concrètement qu'il pourra
donner de l'argent à heat était le trust
qui a organisé le coup d'état au chili
si mitterrand pas les patrons eux
restent et par conséquent nos
revendications demeurent par exemple les
400 francs minimum que demandait il ya
peu de temps mais c'était avant les
élections la cgt la cfdt
les 200 euros d'augmentation pour tous
pour lesquels se sont battus des
dizaines de milliers
d'ailleurs comme ceux de la thomson ou
ceux des chantiers de saint nazaire
l'échelle mobile des salaires façon les
indices de l'insee
mais sur les indices des organisations
syndicales la retraite à 55 ans la
semaine de 35 heures sans diminution de
salaire
l'égalité des droits pour les
travailleurs français immigrés pour les
hommes et les femmes la contraception et
l'avortement libre et gratuit pour tout
y compris pour les mineurs parce que si
cette voie du cassiot immédiat ne sont
même pas satisfaites par un gouvernement
de gauche
comment peut-on prétendre changer la vie
même un tout petit peu nous avertissons
françois mitterrand nous ne voulons pas
d'un gouvernement guy mollet willy
brandt wilson nous nous voulons
réellement changer la vie mais pour cela
il ne peut pas y avoir de trêve avec le
patronat nous savons d'ailleurs que la
bourgeoisie se prépare à une telle
expérience et qu'elle peut essayer de
faire ce qu'elle a déjà fait en espagne
en indonésie en grèce ayez au chili or
mitterrand pas plus que le président
allende ne veut s'attaquer un tant soit
peu à l'appareil d'état il prétend même
respecter la constitution de 1958 qui
est quand même une constitution issu
d'un coup d'état militaire celui d'alger
qu'il prétend laisser intact l'armée et
la police
créer du quai entraîné contre les
travailleurs jamais contre les patrons
les travailleurs doivent dès à présent
prévenir tous les mains su tous les
apprentis pinochet français que même si
mitterrand peut être si complaisant à
leur égard que les dirigeants d'unité
populaire au chili eux ne marcheront pas
ils ont tiré toutes les leçons de
l'expérience chilienne et qu'ils agiront
avant qu'il ne soit trop tard
alors on nous dit mais vous êtes des
gauchistes d irréaliste vous voulez tout
tout de suite
nous disons non parfois les travailleurs
sont amenés à faire des compromis et
nous disons aux dirigeants du
la gauche si aujourd'hui vous sacrifier
les luttes des travailleurs pour gagner
quelques voix à droite
si demain vous tendez l'annoncent deux
fils et réactionnaire pour ne pas
effrayer les bourgeois si vous leur
laissez tous les leviers de commande
dans les mains mais alors vous allez
désormais la classe ouvrière et vous
allez laisser tout le loisir à la
bourgeoisie de s'organiser pour préparer
une contre offensive
voilà l'ensemble des problèmes que nous
allons développer pendant cette campagne
et si nous aiderons mi temps à passer au
deuxième tour il importe dès maintenant
de préparer en toute lucidité les
prochaines échéances de combat parce
qu'on ne construit pas le socialisme par
surprise
ou alors on surprend la classe ouvrière
mais pas la bourgeoisie
[Musique]